this video is sponsored by Squarespace
start your free trial today at WWF
acecomm second thought to get 10% off
your first purchase
imagine one decision you've made
recently we all make hundreds of
decisions every day
some of them much more important than
others take for example your morning
commute every day you go from point A
your home to point B your place of
employment on the way you'll make
numerous decisions should I go the speed
limit or just a little over or a lot
over should I stop for coffee Starbucks
or Dunkin Donuts should I clip this guy
on the bike who's clearly not in the
bike lane you get the picture in each of
these scenarios you make your decision
and move on and any other possibilities
become null and void but what if you
really performed all of those possible
actions simultaneously it sounds
impossible but the general concept is a
staple and what's broadly referred to as
multiverse theory the idea is that for
every potential outcome for any given
situation there is a separate and
distinct universe in which that outcome
did happen so there would be a separate
universe for stopping at Starbucks on
your way to work and another one for
stopping at Dunkin Donuts each occurring
simultaneously in their own unique
timeline if we extrapolate this to
existence in general there's an
alternate timeline in which your
favorite sports team didn't lose that
big game one where the Russians beat the
United States to the moon one where
Henry Ford decided to collect stamps
instead of pursue his idea of a
motorized carriage basically anything
that could happen does happen and things
that couldn't happen also happen but
we're getting out of ourselves the idea
that there could be more universes in
existence than just our own dates back
to at least 1952 when Aaron Schrodinger
stated that when his Nobel equations
seemed to describe several different
histories these were not alternatives
but all really happened simultaneously
that being said it's nearly impossible
to pin down a date for the inception of
multiverse theory because it consists of
many very different and often
fundamentally opposing hypotheses for
example the idea of parallel or
alternate timelines exists not only in
physics and astronomy but also cosmology
religion philosophy and psychology not
to mention science fiction and fantasy
literature but let's look at the
scientific side of things what kind of
support is there for the theory of
multiple universes well not much there
has been and continues to be heated
debate over whether or not multiverse
theory holds water
but more than that many scientists
believe that not only is the whole idea
silly it could erode public perception
of real science and damage the study of
fundamental physics harsh accusations to
be sure but not without cause the basis
of the scientific method is asking a
question forming a testable hypothesis
gathering empirical data and evaluating
the findings the scientists opposed to
the study of multiverse theory suggests
that this testability is the key issue
how can any experiment rule out a theory
if the theory provides for all possible
outcomes this is a valid concern but for
the sake of this video let's explore a
few different possible types of
multiverse the American theoretical
physicist and string theorist Brian
Greene lists nine possible variants of
multiverse each with unique
characteristics we'll take a look at
four of the more interesting ones first
there's the possibility of what's called
a quilted universe this explanation only
works in an infinite universe but if we
assume that our own universe is infinite
it's not an unreasonable hypothesis in a
quilted universe since distance and time
is infinite every possible event within
our laws of physics will happen an
infinite number of times however the
speed of light would prevent us from
ever seeing the evidence of such
identical sections of universe that
seems fairly straightforward right let's
look at a slightly more complicated
variant the membrane or brane hypothesis
suggests that many separate universes
exist in three-dimensional form within a
larger multi-dimensional space or bulk
think of it this way when you buy
printer paper you get hundreds of sheets
bundled inside a wrapper the wrapper is
like the bulk and the individual sheets
of paper are unique universes within
this bulk the universes can drift around
and interact with one another and every
few trillion years or so drawn together
by gravity or other forces we can't yet
comprehend they collide with one another
in a violent explosion triggering what
we know as a Big Bang at that point they
could bounce off each other like
billiard balls combined into a new super
universe or perhaps most likely given
our current understanding of the Big
Bang spark the creation of a new
universe from the violent destruction of
the old ones
then there's the theory most reminiscent
of the example at the beginning of this
video the quantum universe hypothesis
this version of the multiverse theory
suggests that a new you
is created every time a diversion event
occurs such as choosing to call in sick
to work there would be one universe
based on the consequences of going into
work like normal and another new one for
the events that transpire after calling
in sick this multiverse would grow
exponentially and infinitely as every
person on earth makes hundreds of
decisions every day and those decisions
cause a new set of decisions and so on
it's a fascinating theory and one that
seems to capture public interest more
than others finally there's the ultimate
multiverse hypothesis this one tends to
draw a lot of criticism from the
scientific community perhaps rightfully
so the ultimate multiverse hypothesis
suggests that it would contain every
mathematically possible universe under
different laws of physics that last part
is what gets it in trouble not only does
it consider our laws of physics the ones
we assume to be universal but it goes so
far as to say all possible universes
within all possible variants of physics
there's simply no way to test the
hypothesis which relegates it more to
the realm of philosophy than hard
science of course many scientists
consider the multiverse theory as a
whole to be more philosophical than
empirical whether they're right or not
remains to be seen as so far we don't
have any evidence for the existence of
any universe but our own but hey maybe
we're in a universe where the laws of
physics don't allow us to detect the
billions of other universes floating all
around us I'd like to take a moment to
thank my sponsor Squarespace for making
this video possible Squarespace is a
sleek super user-friendly platform that
lets you create stunning websites with
zero experience required some of the
world's biggest companies celebrities
and even your favorite youtubers use
Squarespace to build their own
professional websites if you watch
real-life lore you've probably heard
about our super secret project we're
working on he and I are currently
designing our collaborative website with
Squarespace and we'll be sure to share
it with you when we're done
as a little thank you for watching
Squarespace is offering my viewers 10%
off your first purchase with them just
go to Squarespace comm slash second
thought or click the link in the
description to sign up and start
building your online presence that
Squarespace comm / second thought to
start your very own professional website
today if you enjoyed this video make
sure to subscribe to keep up to date
with the latest content you can watch my
previous video by clicking here or if
you're really bored you can watch all my
us by clicking here don't forget to
check out the new Waterworld Instagram
and if you'd really like to support my
channel consider becoming a patron on
patreon thanks for watching and I'll see
you in the next video